the man circled here is heckling prince
andrew during the procession of the
queen's coffin through edinburgh
in response many drowned him out
chanting god save the king
then someone in the crowd decided they'd
had enough
[Applause]
on the pavement behind the crowd police
try to calm the situation as tempers
among the public are
oh raised i've done nothing wrong
monarchist or republican most will
consider this a time to reflect on an
incredible life of service but some will
want the queen's passing to signal the
end of the institution itself and make
themselves heard
[Music]
in response to protesters police have
either moved people on or in some
instances made arrests two people in
edinburgh have been charged
so i called out who elected him
after saying that at a proclamation of
the king in oxford on sunday simon hill
was handcuffed and detained by the
police are we really now in a place in
21st century britain where a new head of
state is proclaimed uh we're told to
accept this person without without any
question and somebody who speaks out
against it is he is dragged off and
arrested it felt like a
like i
slipped into the 16th century for a
minute
policing events leading up to the
queen's funeral is a large and complex
operation and there are new laws around
protests
the police crime sentencing and courts
act which became law this year gives
police more powers to disrupt protests
if they're deemed to be causing
significant harm to those nearby
interpretation of that depends on the
circumstances and the sensitivities and
the complication here is we have two
things happening at once a moment of
national mourning but also the
proclamation of a new king a big
constitutional change
well this is absolutely the time to talk
about the future of the monarchy because
we have a pneumonic and um you know
charles has become king without consent
without discussion or debate it's just
happened automatically
and there is
no effort to have a serious debate about
that and that is completely wrong
but people coming to pay their respects
in windsor say this isn't the week for
it they wouldn't do it would they if the
lady down the road died would they
yeah so you're talking about the monarch
of this country has been around for 70
years
i think that's just disrespectful some
people might be saying well they're
protesting against the new king not
against them well i think i think at the
end of the day
whoever it is
you know whether it's politics or in
royalty give them a chance
i don't think should be arrested i'd
probably just totally ignore them
this hereditary transfer of power is
something we've not seen in 70 years
it's bound to have a mixed reception
several protest groups have said they
won't campaign during this time of
mourning but some will and it's the
police in the first instance he'll have
to decide what is and isn't appropriate
jason farrell sky news